thousands of years ago some of our
prehistoric ancestors walked across a
field in the modern nation of tanzania
and left footsteps that would last for
millennia
now they're part of the largest fossil
footprint site ever found
on the african continent footprints we
make on a sandy beach can be washed away
in minutes
but these made in volcanic ash have
survived for thousands of years
dr kevin attalo with chatham university
is working the site near the village
of hungary cerro when we found this site
and found that it had
more than 400 footprints preserved on it
we immediately knew that this was
a pretty big deal big deal i'd say i
mean what has to
happen in order for these footprints to
be preserved
well these footprints they were made in
wet volcanic ash and when that ash dried
it turned to something almost like
concrete
the site discovered by a member of the
maasai people back in 2006
is roughly the size of a tennis court it
contains
408 prints estimated to have been made
between
6 000 and 19 000 years ago
the big question who made these
footprints
we actually think that a group of them
were made by
17 individuals who were traveling across
the surface together
we estimate that within that group there
were probably 14 adult females two adult
males
and maybe one adolescent who are all
traveling together
is there anything you can tell us about
why they happen to be
taking that stroll that day where you
tend to see this kind of group structure
where you see
many adult females walking together
traveling together in the absence of
very many males
or children is during foraging
activities and so when a group of
adult women might go out to forage for
food and so
that's been our guess while it's
incredible that it survived it all
the concern now is that the discovery
doesn't lead to its destruction
we want to develop a plan with the
tanzanian government
that we know can help to preserve this
site for a very long time it's been
there for thousands of years we would
like for it to be there for us
thousands and thousands of more years if
that's possible
covet hampering that a bit but this is a
project by the smithsonian
appalachian state university and
george washington so chatham university
and that scientists are doing a great
job
yeah amazing what they've been able to
preserve what they were able to find